hey this is wild uh this crazy trumpest
republican candidate carrie lake
she lost it when fox news's brett bayer
confronted her about her hypocrisy on
drag queens now
in case you don't know about drag queens
drag queens are typically we're talking
about male performers
who use what's called drag clothing and
makeup to imitate and sometimes even
exaggerate
female gender signifiers
but it's entertainment purposes
drag queens are not trans people you
might have trans drag queens but when we
talk about drag queens we're talking
about sort of like a performance uh
thing we're not talking about
um
transgender people okay fine so carrie
lake
has been uh viciously going after
drag queens and people who enjoy drag
queens and all these different things
and it turns out that a drag queen came
out and said i've performed for carrie
lake carrie lake has hired drag queens
to perform multiple times she's a
hypocrite okay so she goes on fox news
bret bayer confronts her she didn't
expect to be confronted about this on
fox news and she flips out it says
arizona gop candidate who criticized
drag queens was once a fan according to
a drag queen this is the quote arizona
gop gubernatorial way it's obviously so
stupid what's going on but she is a
hypocrite and good for bret baer for
asking her about it and carrie lake who
has attacked drag queens as dangerous to
children attended the shows of drag
queen richard stevens for more than 20
years and once hired him to perform at
her home do you care to address that i
do care i actually do care to address
that and i'm really shocked
i'm actually appalled
that fox news would take defamatory
story like that and we are pursuing
legal action against this drag queen
sue the drag queen i'm appalled that you
would bring that up when you have not
talked about or stolen election you've
failed you just spent three questions mr
lake talking about this i just asked you
a number of questions about it i played
the arizona this is the first let's
address let's address this story that's
in the washington post every candidate
takes tough stories i'm asking you to
respond to it if you'd like to i'm happy
to address it but i'm really
disappointed in fox i thought you were a
little better than cnn i'm really
disappointed
this is a person who i covered for
decades for decades 20 years
and he's never been in my home he says
he's been in my home for a drag show
that's ludicrous he's never been in my
home he's lied we tried to serve him
defamation papers okay and he's so shady
that we can't even track him down
because he's not even welcome at the
places where it works i'm sorry but this
is the last question i'm going to ask
what about these pictures of you with
him
isn't that the best what about the
pictures where you're together richard
stevens
what about this the post i've performed
for carrie's birthday i've performed in
her home i've performed for her at some
of the seediest bars in phoenix i don't
want to ask these questions i ask you to
address them
i think you do want to ask him but you
don't want to ask about two thousand
mules right i think ganesh de sousa film
dude that's the real issue guys do want
to ask about this this is absolutely
ludicrous i'm i'm talking about drag
shows in schools this is what triggered
this man somebody who goes to a drag
show with female impersonators is one
thing we don't want our tax money going
into drag shows at school okay i
understand what you're making a
difference there but you're saying his
allegations are wrong is what you're
saying
yes i am all right and i'm despite the
pictures the allegations are completely
untrue
unhinged unhinged and this is what it
has come down to folks these people are
out of their minds and they might win in
november
if we don't get out and vote we'll have
these clips on our instagram find us on
instagram at david pakman show
our sponsor javi makes coffee from
concentrate this is so fast and easy and
convenient and i'm looking for fast easy
and convenient right now but i don't
want to sacrifice on flavor the taste is
great it's cost effective you can use it
for hot or cold coffee it comes in
original decaf caramel or caramel please
pick whichever pronunciation you want
french vanilla and mocha it does not
have sugar it does not have dairy you
can add whatever liquid you want water
milk oat milk etc the ingredients are
delicious coffee concentrate and for the
flavored ones natural flavors the coffee
is ethically sourced
click the link in the description
use code pacman for 25 off